all right so a fair bit of warning when
you get out of a movie and you see a
line of about 3,000 fifteen-year-old
girls waiting to see the movie that you
just saw it's not strange it's just the
Hunger Games The Hunger Games all right
so the Hunger Games movie just like the
book has an enormous amount of hype
around it and to be fair a couple days
ago I sat down and I read The Hunger
Games book I won't compare the movie to
the book too much I know how you know I
know how that can be they can be
annoying but it's almost inevitable
rights won The Hunger Games there are
twelve districts that all make up a
nation there used to be 13 but number 13
it's gone now and each of these 12
districts has to offer up one girl and
one boy to compete in The Hunger Games
which is you take the contestants put
them in the wilderness somewhere
broadcast it live to the entire nation
they'll fight to the death till there's
the last one standing and there's the
Hunger Games good yeah it's good be it
overhyped a bit so first of all Katniss
Everdeen played by Jennifer Lawrence I
really liked her in this movie she's
perfect as Katniss she's awesome she's
badass she's not really warm and fuzzy
you think oh she's a chick she's gonna
be like you know emotional chick she's
actually pretty cold she's had to adapt
she lives in district 12 which is pretty
much like the [ __ ] district feature
movies have one thing in common when
you're broke-ass poor you are broke-ass
poor you look like you live in the slums
of 1864 when you're rich you look like
you live in the year two thousand six
hundred and while Katniss is being
trained we have Woody Harrelson he plays
hey Mitch hey Mitch was a boy from
district 12 who actually won the Hunger
Games now he's a man and he gets to
Train Katniss and Peeta the two from
district 12 who were competing in the
Hunger Games
and actually liked him as hey Mitch he's
a drunk slob he's kind of funny doesn't
like the politics and [ __ ] I like
that about him and I liked how the
Hunger Games shows that yeah you can
kill people all you want but you want
the people to like you so you get
sponsorship no though Katniss is really
good at killing people no it's so good
at having people like her so then we get
to the main event the wilderness the
Hunger Games and yeah people start
slicing each other up and dying and at
that point you still like The Hunger
Games but it's not as exciting as you
think it would be I mean you would think
it's a really cool thing you know
survival of the fittest for throwing
Darwinism at the wall here seeing who
sticks in the end it's you know it has
it's exciting parts also has its slow
parts I mean there are a couple of
situational circumstances like she gets
this little pal in the movie you're
supposed to care about this little pal
you're really down and there's
this kind of romance blooming with her
and Peeta the guy from district 12 that
she's there with but really you don't
buy it I mean there's no weather way to
stay so I'm just gonna hit you in the
face with it you don't really buy the
fact that she gives a [ __ ] about him and
it is illustrated in the book that at
first she doesn't she's just doing it to
play to the audience so she gets
sponsorship but at a point she actually
ends up liking the dude in this movie I
never really bought that she actually
cared about it the argument could be
dude yeah she didn't want him to die or
anything she must love him it's not how
I saw it I saw it as oh you're a good
person I don't want you to get killed
not like oh I don't want you to eat kill
because I love you you cannot want
someone to die just because you're a
decent human being like there's a scene
in the book they spent a lot of time in
this cave you know because they got to
heal up and whatnot and it gives time
for them to kind of bond in the book it
was way too long rules like all right
dude get back to the killing I'm just
that kind of person I guess but in the
movie it breezes right by it so you're
like alright dude show why they care
somewhere there is a happy medium that I
would have liked to have seen in either
medium it just wasn't there and I
thought they handled an element of the
storytelling really well The Hunger
Games book is written in first person so
when things are going down you can read
her thoughts on the subject the movie
doesn't have that luxury so they need to
tell you information without it being
forced so in that they go to Stanley
Tucci in the broadcasters who are
commentating throughout the Hunger Games
on TV and they tell you the viewer the
information I thought that was a really
good way to do it and Stanley Tucci
rocks and so do his teeth so good acting
I like the premise I like the world
they've built in The Hunger Games I had
some excitement it had some boring parts
I had a romance I didn't really buy in
the end I will say The Hunger Games is a
good time no alcohol required it's good
it's enjoyable but it's not like the
Christ you've been told it's supposed to
be if you love the books you're gonna
like the movie if you don't like The
Hunger Games at all the movies not gonna
win you over or so there are a few
battle to the death type movies you know
what's your favorite battle to the death
last one standing and broadcasted on
television if we're lucky your favorite
movie of that type comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more